we know that endoplasmic reticulum is a
factory that folds protein quality
controls protein folding and also
delivers the protein to a warehouse and
that warehouse is Golgi apparatus from
the Golgi apparatus these proteins are
differentially sorted for delivery to
either a cell membrane or lysosome or
mitochondria or many other locations
inside the cell but in order to deliver
it to specific locations either outside
of the cell or there some specific
organelle inside the cell cell needs
specialized vesicles which are just like
trucks which would leave the warehouse
to deliver the parcels in specific
locations in the city so in this video
we would look at one that kind of truck
which is known as clattering coated
vesicles so as the name suggests it is
clathrin-coated so it is coated by
clattering and clattering is produced by
a complicated lattice of Triskelion
molecules the Triskelion molecules as
depicted here has a heavy chain of 180
killer Alton and light chain of 35 kilo
Dalton and these Triskelion residues
attaches to each other at it at their
head domain and from the complicated
clattering lattice all around the
vesicle this kind of Lateran coat helped
to ensure that the vesicle identity is
maintained while it is transported now
we follow the endocytosis of one
receptor which is which is going to be
endocytosed
and a clattering coat would be formed so
here is a receptor a chi protein coupled
receptor
now it is undergoing a ligand induced
endocytosis so several adaptor proteins
such as beta arrestin would invite other
adapters like a p2 now a p2 or adapter
protein 2 is very important because
adaptor protein 2 serves as a platform
where these Triskelion molecule can
associate and build up in form format of
a vesicle there are additional Birdmen
proteins which binds around these
receptor complex to create membrane
curvature and allow the membrane to come
inside this forming coat now once it is
happening the membrane is evaluated in
version ated and the clattering quote is
building up around this invaginate Adnan
situation now after a while the
clattering coat is ready and it is
hanging from a membrane at a small stock
specialized protein such as china mean
associates there and died an amine is a
gtp s and it sort of pinch off the
vesicle from the membrane as a result
the vesicle is released from the
membrane and it is endocytosed once it
is endocytosed there are several and
enmity has reached its destination
there are several proteins such as
oxygen and HSC 70 chaperones which help
to disassociate the coats
now when the when the sort of you can
imagine this thing is like when the
parcel is reaching its destination then
it is not required to be coated properly
right for protection so now the code
could be remove or the protection could
be remove to reveal the person so
similarly inside the cell the class
dreamcourt is removed when the vesicle
which is endocytosed
is reaching its
nation with the help of oxygen and HSE
70 now we look at where does Catherine
courted endocytosis happening and where
does where other places as clatter
encoding is required so clatter encoded
endocytosis happens from wherever the
proteins that are trying to get
endocytosed from outside of the cell
those vesicles are budding off with a
clattering code on it and they are
mostly fuse with early endosome
apart from that vesicles metal budding
out from the trans-golgi network also
seems to have clustering coat around
them apart from clattering code there
are two other type of coated vesicles
like cop 1 and cop 2 coded vesicle cop 1
coded vesicle is important for
retrograde transport from ER to Golgi
and cop 2 coded vesicle is helpful for
interrogate transport from ear to
ecology now about this cop 1 and cop 2
coded vesicle I have a separate video
you can watch this on the link on the
end screen I hope you enjoyed this video
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you